hallo liebe also mal bahn und heute gibt
es ein ganz gutes video mit meiner
liebsten liebsten allerdings in can eat
und zwar hat mir ein spiel ausgedacht
und teils ganz einfach wir machen panto
activity nabu in einer privat habe ich
sagen darf dass angriff stimmt aber
umgekehrt michael faschon wir machen ihn
flach und behandlung wird sie erwarten
genau und werde
er hat gewonnen was natürlich echt sein
ich bin schon sehr er großzügig gelacht
wie möglich raus ich habe dann gefragt
und wir haben den ganzen abend
beobachten richtig kleine okay mein
erstes
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ich habe ein buch von anrufen aus die
gründer kommen
[Gelächter]
okay okay okay
[Musik]
im dritten spiel
vielleicht müssen mehr schwerer und
nimmt leichter ab 11
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
da muss ich sagen damit ist herr design
heute morgen aufgewacht ist
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
doch nur weil du so macht menschen ums
leben
[Musik]
ich bin sehr gespannt was von mir also
ohne druck zu machen
das muss sein zwei so verkniffen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
wir haben natürlich wieder gefangen wenn
ja dann gibt einen daumen nach oben und
geht auf jeden fall auf hennings kanal
denn da haben wir auch ein video gedreht
und dann das nächste mal